I think it's too easy to just say that
there is a direct and necessary conflict
between black identity and gay identity
I think it's more nuanced than that
simply because I think black is a color
and then we people layer on top of it
all kinds of socio-cultural elements I
think there's a necessary conflict right
now between the the vehemently religious
and the LGBT community the the extremes
of religion I think and the LGBT
community have an issue and because a
lot of black families in America have
are more religious I think that's where
the conflict comes into play but I also
think that we just don't you you can't
identify you can't label identity in the
kind of ways that we do you know if I if
I understand enough of what it was to be
gay
from popular culture in America and in
Britain basically then I just wouldn't
fit you know because there are no gay
people a lot like this I would you know
I would have to change everything I
would have to change the drink that I'd
choose to drink I'd have to change the
clothes that I wear everything and the
same with being black the we we need to
get past the point where being black and
a male means that I am likely to mug you
for your wallet likely to have a minus
15 on my IQ likely to not go to college
and like least wear my pants below my
arse I mean there's there's more nuance
what it is to be black I think if we got
to that point perhaps we would see the
conflicts between black what it is to be
black and what it is to be gay within
individuals as well as in communities
dissipate
I think we are falling foul of our own
stereotypes with within the LGBT
community the idea that you can tell
what gay is by looking at it there's
really pervasive you know I haven't
often but I have occasionally
experienced the fact that I walk up to
the door of a gay bar and be knocked
back because people look at me and say
well you you know you can't possibly be
gay you know kiss him I was like I don't
know him I'm not gonna but I think if we
really want to if we really want to
advance our cause in terms of taking our
place as a valued part of the spectrum
of diversity then we need to look within
the LGBT community and say within us
there is the similar spectrum there is
there are parts of us that are very very
different and that can be found across
the country and across the world and we
need to embrace each bit of that and
that and that includes ending things
like people writing straight acting on
their profiles as if to be camp is is
awful we need to accept that some people
are camp and some people are butch some
people are pretty and some people are
average but we all fit